plus à l'est on termine ce jour cette
émission par des questions en 4/3 alors
on fait dans ce but il est question
enquête hier et pour cette question aux
costières
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai pas mis à jeter des coups vous
allez craquer devant son poste
alors il a donc fallu qu on lance les
cravates balances ton post est oui alors
aujourd'hui que je suis avec toi je
boitais parole allez une question tout
de suite pour les questions aux
enquêteurs ont beau bonjour je m'appelle
catherine j'aime beaucoup votre émission
il ya quelque chose que je ne comprends
pas et qui m'énerve pourquoi tous les
soirs derrière vous il ya une dame
blonde du public qui n'a pas droit de
s'asseoir avec les autres boîtiers
grosse méprise ce n'est pas une dame du
public d'ailleurs series c'est kelly si
elle est derrière ce n'est pas parce
qu'elle est puni c'est parce qu'elle est
jolie n'a rien à voir physique
en comparaison les autres qui ont un
physique plus difficiles sont assis
kylie qui est donc arrivé en tant que dj
t qui devient au fur et à mesure la
mascotte du plateau on va s'arrêter
1 parce que tous les soirs avec daniel
enfin c'est un peu tordu c'est un peu
tendu parce que je vous raconte tout on
va dire la vérité entre mathieu et elle
tous les soirs c'est la guerre des
fausses blondes et j'en peux plus de
cette tension
quoi alors pour me libérer je vous ai
fait une petite compil serrer les dents
[Musique]
bientôt divulgué
alors cet allumé dans des verres
[Musique]
l'abrégé la brigitte bardot de bedous
vraiment je m mais bernard me vois comme
je te rappelle
[Musique]
pour sandra jalouse déjà dit si bien
[Applaudissements]
qu'elle n'a pas de zz rappelle que
mathieu un doctorat de psychologie elle
me tourne autour c'est insupportable
pour notre génération qu'elle vous évite
je veux vous dire ma vérité
daniel est un peu d'accord avec moi si
elle est un petit peu avec mathieu c'est
chez moi ils te fuis fuis l'aï lu mais
la guerre je suis un petit peu
d'analystes
évidemment il c'est vrai que si
reconnaissable si je cherche mais ces
quelques pas de trouver msqn but c'est
vrai plaisir de dîner avec toi c'est
pourquoi sa vie aux mille tonnes hissée
le temps je me retrouve pas ce que vaut
le coup d'y croire je promets que c'est
vrai j'ai essayé de comprendre pourquoi
ai je répondu je réponds toujours
important et je pense que ce qui rend
nerveux ce qui est lisse et c'est
l'arrivée de daniel moreau dans l'équipe
maintenant la concurrente à sa taille
parce qu'au début on pensait tous que
daniel aller nous amener un peu de calme
et de camomille dans l'équipe
en fait c'est elle qui est le plus près
d'al celle la plus offensive alors dans
les dernières chrétiens j'avais déjà
montré les perches qu'elle avait tendu
avoir sonné clos ou ghosting galiana
mais en fait c'est tout le temps elle
pense qu'à ça la bougresse
[Rires]
anthony colette et rythmé tonnerre donc
son danseur réel ça y est ça c'est pêchu
qu'est ce qu'un daniel partenaires et
ssq à 5,15 adams et les gens aiment
participer
non parce que je suis très connu mais
aux états unis avec dicaprio souvent
mise est beaucoup plus beau pedigree
prix alors ben moi je me sens rappelle
franck 30 ans quand tu fais pas ça
marche bien ça ça pique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2 ça montparnasse
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais toujours dans les limites vraiment
du raisonnable
ouais c'est pour ça que vous êtes
baseball mais j'ai tellement de temps
aujourd'hui tu vois pas ce que elle a
fait la connaissance d'un garçon cette
semaine ah oui frédéric ah oui oui ils
ont tendu par des tireurs
on en est où nicher sur le plateau on a
eu l'impression qu'il va arriver avec
vraiment ouais j'ai un peu cru mais pour
l'instant j'ai pas de nouvelles bombes
auraient recueilli là il a alors fallu
ce qu'on dit en amour a pas de nouvelle
très mauvaise il a 2 il a deux concerts
la semaine prochaine de ce peuple sa
culture et son numéro et à 10,34 nous
aurait fait porter son disque là avec la
femme linda soir mon wii donc mais après
je n'ai pas de nouvelles écoutes
c'est vrai qu'il est timide mais en même
temps j'ai vu qu'ils regardaient kelly
bizarrement onu en amoureux de la
musique me rassurer ouais je pense que
ça peut se faire
la réaction la plus mignonne de la
semaine maintenant on la doit à maxime
gay ni à la mère supérieure du plateau
alors je me situe mathieu nous raconter
un rencard avec l'amour de sa vie
non je déconne avec un inconnu comme
d'habitude et là jean michel le sniper
va tenter une vanne imposer enfin un peu
osée pour nous mais beaucoup trop osé
pour maxime
regardez sa tête je pense que s'il avait
pu il aurait envoyé jean michel direct
en pension vous l'avez connu e ht
connaissent pas ne voulait connu sur les
réseaux qu on a discuté et alors elle et
quand on s'intéresse aux gens et qu'on
aime les gens on discute on est curieux
et bien malade
et on repart en boitant
il
m
aujourd'hui c'est pas à lui et puis là
osé et il me regarde quand ils achètent
parfois quand même sentir il est à fond
tu n'arrêtes pas merci khalid sur les
meilleurs est pas allé bug transition
pour le top j'ai dansé extrait
inclassable de tpm p
[Musique]
[Rires]
devenus les cordes et on est déjà son
troisième saut
[Musique]
c'est être seul c'est d'être là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est clovis
aucun jeu où les candidats on leur
injecte du gaz dans le rectum au nom au
nom
[Musique]
trois français qui ont accepté d'évoquer
sans tabou leurs problèmes de sexualité
trouble de l'érection le désirent enfin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a souhaité bon anniversaire et
d'agrandir la famille royale
d'angleterre a varié depuis mai dernier
à meghan markle lors d'une série soit
quéval anniversaire à gan semble vivre
une parfaite j'ai découvert ça sur le
lien avec l'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
mais je voudrais dire d'ailleurs agathe
elle va d'aujourd'hui instant on lui
souhaite encore un bon anniversaire à
gagne 27 ans l'a souvent les contraintes
sont diverses c'est le 10 mars
l'anniversaire d'un vous avez mars
chaque année je rigole pas on s'envoie
des anniversaires nous envoyer vos
bonnes anniversaire le 23 septembre à
turin
c'est un dimanche matin mais il a été un
des premiers à m'envoyer bon
anniversaire donc voilà je revois les
jours c'est vrai des premiers
jean-luc on a toujours des règles qui va
regarder un quoi y'en a plus d'ennemis
on va s'ennuyer vous inquiétez pas alors
dans le temps que j'énonce j'aurais
aussi pu mettre une phrase de jacques
séguéla qui est passée complètement
inaperçue et pourtant tellement drôle et
maladroite vous allez voir là il
expliqué ce qui arrivait aux hommes
politiques qui se laissait les des
écarts de langage comment ils risquaient
de finir ça lui a coûté l'élection c'est
ça la seule chose sûre un mauvais mot
c'est pour ça que quand on représente la
france
il faut choisir ses mots noms changent
de métier on est animateur il fallait il
en appelle à la gym
ouais ouais tu regardes tu crois que
c'est gilles non c'est un moment que
vous parler un petit peu vous vous
rencontriez c'est bernard on va briser
la glace entre les deux sacs et non non
c'est pas ça on en reparlera inquiétez
pas c'est s'est séparé connaissent
encore du tout aller aux fins d'une
séance d'uv
il aime tout le monde feint d'amour donc
c'est sûr qu'ils lui qui aime tout le
monde aime personnes patrick bruel
extraits de chansons d'or de patrick
bruel
mais il a une culture celui-ci cabarry
60 ans alors qu a écrit qui a écrit le
grand meaulnes ob1 fournier et on est en
retard
[Applaudissements]
vous avez ces pompes les animateurs mais
pas pour les gens qui représente la
france
et pourtant c'est un métier très
difficile animateurs je le vois tous les
vendredis moi j'ai l'impression d'être
un éducateur qui s'occupe des ados
difficiles parce qu'il y ait des
rebelles dans le groupe 1 regardez juste
la différence de comportement quand jean
michel est avec moi ou avec cyril non à
témoin elle met des coups de pression
jean michel maire le plus le mec le plus
libidineux de france je t'emmerde
[Musique]
j'ai toutes les infos sera en quête de
bas mais vraiment toutes les infos je
suis désolé j'ai reçu un texto de justin
bieber
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que vous êtes bon c'est pas
facile
on est comme ça allait comme ça je suis
demandé d'où venait ce respect de
jean-michel pour rares hormis des
raisons financières évidentes on a un
peu plus sous mais quand même avec
plaisir mon jean luc hallé on commence
par matthieu delormeau qui a priori n'a
pas regardé la coupe du monde cet été
[Musique]
soria qui est quoi ce qui t'aime
beaucoup et qui m'a dit est ce que
pascal cherche une choriste cherche pas
une coiffeuse mais c est bien fait mais
on ne sait pas ce que vous êtes très
belle et donc voilà pour moi vous me
rappelez billion de ces foyers des
gueugnonnais
laeticia hallyday il faut maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
les banques
service après-vente de tpb bonjour
bonjour
[Musique]
redécouvrir gijon 0 1
couture a certainement nous bercer par
le travail toucher un peu mais
volontiers avec ses partenaires si je
suis excité fait attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait on m'avait posé la question
qu'est ce qui ferait que je partirai de
plus belle eve et j'ai dit ben voila si
c'est un gros projet car il
[Musique]
merci mélodies